so the idea here is is to grow this
organically uh we need uh rather like
the academic freedom alliance that
robbie george created earlier this year
we need breadth
and we need to show that this is not
some kind of
institutionalization of the intellectual
dark web
though we welcome founding members of
that
that
nebulous body it's really something
designed for all of academia to provide
a kind of reboot that i i think we all
agree is is needed
is there a george washington type figure
who is is there a president elected yet
or is
who's going to lead this institution
hannah canelos the former president of
st john's is the president of university
of austin and so he is our george
washington
i don't know who alexander hamilton is
i'll lead you to guess
it's funny you mentioned idw
intellectual dark web have you uh
talked to your friend sam harris about
but any others he um
he is another person i really admire and
i've talked to online and offline
quite a bit for
not belonging to any tribe
he
stands boldly on his convictions
when he knows they're not going to be
popular
with like he based
he basically gets canceled by every
group he sort of he doesn't shy away
from controversy
and not for the sake of controversy
itself he is
one of the best examples to me of a
person who thinks freely
i disagree with him on a few quite a few
things
but i deeply admire that he is he he is
what it looks like to think freely by
himself it feels to me like he
represents a lot of the ideals of this
kind of effort yes he would be a natural
fit sam if you're listening i hope
you're in uh i think in in the course of
his recent intellectual
quests he did collide with one of our
founders heather hying so we'll have to
model civil disagreement at the
university of austin it's extremely
important that we should all disagree
about many things but do it
amicably
one of the things that has been lost
sight of perhaps it's all the fault of
twitter or maybe it's something more
profound is that it is possible to
disagree in a civil way and
and still be friends i certainly had
friends at oxford who were far to the
left of me politically and they are
still among my best friends so the
university of austin has to be a place
where we can
disagree
uh we can disagree vehemently but we can
then go and have a beer afterwards
that's that's in my mind a really
important part of university life
learning the difference between the
political and the and the personal so
sam is a i think a a good example as a
you of a certain kind of intellectual
hero
who has
been willing to
go into the
cyber uh sphere the metaverse and carve
out an intellectual
space
uh the the podcast
and
debate everything fearlessly his
uh essay was really an essay on black
lives matter and the question of police
racism was a masterpiece of 2020
and
and so he i think is a
a model of what
we believe in
but we can't save the world with
podcasts good though
yours is
because there's a kind of
solo element
to this form of of public intellectual
activities it's also there in substance
where all our best writers
uh now seem to be including our founder
barry weiss
the danger with this uh approach is
ultimately your subscribers are the
people who already agree with you and we
are all there for
in danger of preaching
to the choir
i think what makes an institution like
university of austin so attractive is
that we get everybody together
uh at least part of the year
and we
do that informal interaction at lunch
at dinner
that allows
in my experience the best ideas to form
intellectual activity isn't really a
solo voyage historians often make it
seem that way but i've realized over
time that
i do my best work in a collaborative way
and scientists have been better at this
than people in the humanities
but what really matters what what's
magical about a good university is that
interdisciplinary serendipitous
conversation that happens on campus
tom sargent the great nobel
prize-winning economist tonight used to
have these
kind of random conversations in
elevators at nyu or in corridors at
stanford and sometimes they'd be quite
short conversations but in that short
serendipitous exchange
i would have
more intellectual stimulus than in in
many a seminar lasting an hour and a
half so
i think we want to get the sam harris's
and and lex friedman's out of their
darkened rooms
and give them a chance to interact in a
a much less structured
way than we've got got used to again
it's that it's that sense that sometimes
you need some freewheeling unstructured
debate to get the really good ideas i
mean to talk anecdotally for a moment i
look back on my oxford undergraduate
experience and i wrote a lot of essays
and attended a lot of classes but
intellectually the most important thing
i did was to write an essay on the
viennese satirist karl krause
for
a an undergraduate discussion group
called the canon club and i probably put
more work into that paper than i put
into anything else except maybe my final
examinations
even although
there was only really one senior member
president the historian jeremy cato i
was really just trying to impress my
contemporaries
and that's the kind of thing
we want
the great intellectuals
the great intellectual leaps forward
occurred
often in somewhat unstructured settings
i'm from scotland you can tell
from my accent a little at least
the enlightenment happened in late 18th
century scotland in a very interesting
interplay between the universities which
were very important uh glasgow edinburgh
st andrews and
the coffee houses and and pubs of
the scottish cities where
a lot of unstructured discussion often
fueled by copious amounts of wine took
place
that's what i've missed over the last
few years let's let's just think about
how hard academic social life has become
that
we've reached the point
that amy chua
becomes the object of a full-blown
investigation and media storm for
inviting to
yale law school students over to her
house
to talk
i mean when i was at oxford it was
regarded as a tremendous honor to be
asked to go to one of our tutors homes
the social life of oxford and cambridge
is one of their great strengths there's
a sort of requirement to
sip unpleasant sherry with the dons and
we've kind of killed all that we've
killed all that in the us because nobody
dares have a social interaction with an
undergraduate or exchange an informal
email in case the whole thing ends up on
the front page of the local or student
newspaper so that that's what we need to
kind of restore the
the social life of academia
you